c'est un moment historique pour
l'allemagne et elle est la réaction du
chancelier kohl qui a décidé
d'interrompre momentanément son voyage
en pologne
quant aux autorités est allemandes elles
sont réunis pour la dernière journée des
travaux du comité central du parti
communiste
ce matin encore de nouveaux changements
au bureau politique ont été annoncés
voici maintenant une scène historique le
parlement ouest allemand à bonn apprend
hier soir la nouvelle les députés sont
alors réunis en séance
regardez la libre circulation des
allemands en allemagne
elle prouve que les dirigeants
est-allemands soigne les actes à la
parole ce soir poursuit hans vogele mes
pensées vont vers l'ex chancelier willy
brandt qui était maire de berlin en août
61 quand le mur a été construit et
tandis que vie libre qui peut plus
cacher son émotion tourner le dos aux
caméras
le bundestag tout entier entonne l'hymne
national celui d'un grand d'allemagne le
même qu'avant la guerre à quelques
phrases prêt devrait assister la nuit
dernière à des scènes incroyables dit le
chancelier kohl sur le mur de berlin
nous vivons un moment rare je veux
souligner que le fait que je vous dis
cela ici était espéré ici devant le
monument aux martyrs du ghetto de
varsovie à cet endroit totalement ne
peut que se sentir en paix de honte
c'est un moment de recueillement ce
qu'on peu chacun pour soi tirer les
vraies leçons de l'histoire